a man named Otto right fantastic movie
nobody's going to see that movie of Tom
Hanks the movie sucks without Tom Hanks
yeah it's nothing without contact yeah
yeah I mean I I I don't know about that
no one would like it if it wasn't I
don't I don't know about that because I
think that the writing is really good I
think that the acting is really good
I knew there was an argument you
wouldn't give a [__] yeah yeah what I'm
saying is nobody would go see it and it
wouldn't get made so it starts with Tom
Hanks and then everybody else yeah yeah
so
yeah what I he didn't like the movie
that much no I thought it was good I
knew there was an argument I thought the
part you didn't like I actually thought
was good oh you suck let's [__] Barry
Diller used to be the uh CEO of
Paramount and uh was part of creating
Fox broadcasting wait why did it suck
thank you yeah that was good I really
enjoyed it I thought the end was really
beautiful I mean I'm not as gay as him
yeah he tells you what part he really
liked no he really got upset about the
trans person and I was like no I get why
they did that because they put a trans
person in the movie and I thought the
point was he's friends with like this
guy hates everybody you don't follow the
rules he doesn't like you he seems so
Surly he keeps calling everybody an
idiot but then this Latina girl who I
think she's a great she was fantastic
she's the best like outside of Tom Hanks
part of the movie but uh then there's a
trans person that was like you know his
wife died and that's why he's extra
miserable trans person of the student of
his wife who's a teacher and I thought
the point of all these like diverse
people is this guy the Hollywood Trope
is you're an old racist person who
changes to not racist throughout the
movie they're making themselves
different than that I mean like no this
guy's open-minded he doesn't care what
race you are he doesn't care what gender
you are he just hates idiots that's his
whole thing you don't follow the rules
you're an idiot you don't park correctly
you're an idiot we need to just make him
that guy who changes throughout the
movie into somebody who accepts everyone
like beyond all that and that couldn't
have been accomplished without the trans
storyline it's the most extreme version
of it and the book he's gay
yeah see what they do how can I see what
they do in The Bookies game but game is
not enough now so Hollywood's like you
have to make him trans
it just felt like so like I I after
being in some movies and like seeing how
this [__] works
well you could put you completed that
the characters trans he's gay like he's
gayer
yeah I see his point they always have to
up the morphine of diversity I see your
boy no hey
there
did I just lose my argument myself I
think so you did you did we're sitting
on that the whole time I know I guess
what I'm saying is like the acting of
the character and their relationship was
fine but it was so obviously a an
executive was like We'll make this movie
but we'd like you to make this trans
because that's the hot button topic
right now and that's the thing that we
need acceptance these gays they've been
accepted so throw them out the [__]
bath water but trans is our way and then
seeing Tom Hanks have to [__]
hold this movie together I mean it was
like Spider-Man you know in the subway
scene Spider-Man 2 and Toby Maguire is
like barely stopping the train from
falling off the tracks he held it was
the most forced [__] and she said
why why does nobody like you I'm trans
and my dad threw me out of the house
because
shut the [__] up no shut up you need
that but you just said it if gay is more
acceptable now you need something all
right good point
actually made it better
no it made it better to highlight his
thing of just like hey I just don't like
idiots that don't follow the rules so
you need extremes because I think a
hacky movie is an old racist an old
white guy is racist and then he meets
some minorities and gay people and now
he's not racist yeah that's so hacky to
me I thought this was different and that
it was like man I don't give a [__] if
you're trans I don't give a [__] if
you're Puerto Rican I don't give a [__]
if you're black I don't care you know
there's a scene where like he's wait
what movies have they put out where it's
the old races guys Clint Eastwood did
one where he [__] hated him Gran
Torino that's what I was thinking of
that happens it happens a lot all the
time yeah yeah that's the thing yes yeah
but if the book was written in like the
60s and the guy was black and it would
have been made amazing in that time if
we saw it now we'd be like ah it's not
it's not that crazy to accept the Box
they didn't even make it like about race
like there's a scene where he has his
best friend who's black and they didn't
talk for decades and it was his best
friend and he talks about how like you
know we were just different any you know
back and you would expect that to be
about race but they lift up their cars
and one has a Ford and one has a Chevy
and he's like this Blue Collar
[__] like I can't believe you
got a Ford Doug I'm a Chevy man we're
such different people and then he said
like I try to patch things up with him
and I realized we had just changed into
different people the black guy's like
hey I want to show you my new car and
then he lifts up the garage and it's a
Toyota and the guy's like I can't
[__] I can't believe I ever was
friends with this guy and it's like he's
the race thing is not an issue at all
yeah it's just he's that stuck in his
ways and that closed-minded so I thought
the trans thing I do agree a bit it's
like you're giving the exact more credit
than I would give him I would think it's
hey we need to make this as diverse as
possible to make everybody happy and not
get yelled at make them trans not gay
but I think it actually highlighted in
the end it worked out because it
highlighted the fact that he don't give
a [__] what you're yeah anything is I
just hate idiots yeah that's what I got
from him I didn't get that it was a play
about whether people whether he was
unaccepting of different races or
cultures yeah I thought it was just
highlighted that the idiot thing was
perfect like he's just he just hates
everybody because he was dealt like a
kind of rough set of cards in life and
I mean it sounds the movie's dope like
he just tries to kill himself constantly
throughout so funny dude like try like
literally tries to kill himself and it's
like
I would really recommend it [__]
tearjerker it's incredible but Tom Hanks
is just so Sensational in his ability to
hold that movie together when that
trance just tried to drop a [__]
nuclear bomb in the middle but if it was
a gay guy still would have worked right
exactly my point but like you could have
made it a Nazi you could have made it
Like A Nazi person like you could have
gotten more extreme to a guy Tom hanks's
age would have worked uh what type of
game flamboyance
oh see that's but he's not a flamboyant
but you can't be in flamboyant trans
you're transitioning into no I mean like
I put them at the same level of like of
what yeah
diversity diversity
I feel like we shouldn't bail him out
come on
diversity
yeah I just hate the force [__] and poor
Tom Hanks have to be like oh damn like
that must be so hard
he didn't say that yeah he did no he
just goes your dad didn't like you
because you're trans he's an idiot
that's all he said yeah yeah he's so mad
about it he was so mad about that you
also made it this big thing and I'm
watching the movie and I'm like how do
we know it's just because it's France
yeah I couldn't even fix a bike the guy
couldn't even fix a [__] bike that's
why your dad doesn't like it we'll put
your bike together for you yeah a
[__] [__] over here
how did you read the book say what read
the book you're just gay in the book
you'll enjoy that I like that yeah he's
good it's also I like that Akash likes
it it's like blue collar guy it's such a
Swedish European book it's a man called
UVA and it's so European
they're fighting over Volvos and skodas
in the book it's a great book really I
bet it is yeah because great books
great movies